all right now let's just take a breath
do you remember back
to when you were first given questions
like this
um something like this i don't know um x
squared minus x
on something like that okay now when you
first met rational functions like this
and had to learn how to graph them
and when you learn calculus you're so
unfamiliar with these and there were so
many steps you like
intercepts vertical asymptotes
horizontal or
oblique or whatever stationary points
there's like 15 things you had to learn
okay and so in order to do this well you
kind of had to
you had to develop an algorithm oh i'm
going to do this and then this
and then this and this and so for
instance the way that i do it this is my
um
i've had longer to think about this one
so i have a nice easy
mnemonic for this you factorize first
right then you work out what your
asymptotes are which are just your x and
y's you work that out from domain
and from the extremities then you work
out your intercepts and then you
use the factors to shade your regions
and say i'm positive negative blah blah
blah
anyway okay now now if i gave you that
question you'd be fine with it because
you've been doing it for so long
but all of this stuff is fresh okay so
i'm going to give you a um an algorithm
for going through
circular motion questions okay now i
tried
and failed to come up with a nice
mnemonic i had no vowels so if you can
come up with
alternative letters for what i'm about
to tell you then um
you're more than welcome and i'd love to
find out
but um there are basically there are
four things you've got to
tick off and then you can work out dudes
okay so
no prizes from me for working out what's
the first one
drawer diving thank you
now the important thing about the
diagram is it's got to have
all the forces on it the forces are the
important thing because
as we go further down the force
equations you what you're going to need
to work with
okay um importantly
like i said before
don't put on mr omega squared it's the
sum of all the resulting forces that are
set heading back toward
the center of motion okay but it's not
an actual physical force like tension
or gravity or or the reaction force off
the table those kinds of things
so draw a diagram right draw all the
forces on it but don't draw
m r omega squared okay because it's the
sum of the forces
the second thing you've got to do is
once you draw your big fancy diagram
okay
you use a combination of whatever trig
and geometry you need to work out now
here's the thing
right this diagram it's all about the
forces
okay the trick in the geometry is to
work out now
where are those forces pointed what
angles right
and how big are those forces okay what
are the magnitude of those forces
so you use trig and geometry to work
that out okay
you might be able to guess what three is
when you've got all of those forces in
real wacky directions you should resolve
them
almost now you you resolve it into the
two different components
right namely um horizontal and vertical
right
okay now once you have those you add
them all up you've got all of your
horizontal forces
they should add up to mr omega squared
you've got all your vertical forces
whatever they are
um usually by the way you've got mr
omega squared here and if it's uniform
circular motion then the vertical forces
should add up to
zero okay final step and this is the
hard part
based on whatever question they're
asking you
you have to solve the force equations
okay you have a couple of them work out
what they're trying to ask you and then
fit in all your information
diagram whatever geometry you need
resolve out all the forces after you
work out the directions
and then solve